alors oui pour la vôtre j'ai besoin d'un
accessoire ou la non non non interview
miroir à l'orgue il
il ressemble à quoi l'homme que vous
voyez dans ce miroir nomme un peu
vieillissant mais encore muse abl ouais
tout à fait vous lui donnez quel âge -
vous le trouver sympathique
oui je touche à magic shook them as dis
parce que je le connais ouais je connais
le vrai ouais donc je sais que c'est un
type bien
en tout cas qui fait des efforts il est
séduisant
ouais on le lui dit souvent
d'après-vous l'homme que vous voyez dans
ce miroir il était beau comme s'ils
étaient jeunes ils ne savaient pas mais
on le lui a prouvé
parfois il est heureux l'homme que oui
dans le miroir la plupart trop
malheureux pour sa vie à lui
ça va s'il a un peu mal au monde
c'est du mal à te regarder là parce que
j'ai une petite correction quand d'après
vous c'est quoi son métier à ce mec là
moi je le connais oui c'est un débat
c'est un acteur qui s'est égaré ou
musicaux et
et qui peut en effet être aussi acteur
humoriste et peut-être même parfois et
il a roulé mais bien ce mec là je ne
déteste pas vous dire que je suis
entouré de gens qui qui m'aident à
l'aimer ouais enfin l'e mail supporter
et les jours je me supporte pas je peux
toujours d'accord avec moi ouais nan
mais pour nous qu'est ce qui vous plaît
le moins dans cet homme cette sorte de
deux cafarde mélancolie un peu morbide
c'est l'enfance ouais un peu hein on
guérit jamais de son enfance
bah non c'est quoi la différence
principale entre vous et l'homme dans ce
miroir c'est que moi je le regardais 8
pas ouais si vous le rencontriez pour de
vrai qu'est ce que vous aimeriez lui
dire à cet homme reste encore un peu